This is how much plaque grows on your teeth after not brushing them for a
single day. Now,
this is just one day of not brushing your teeth,
but what would happen if you decided to stop brushing
forever? How much bacteria lives inside your mouth?
How could this affect your overall health and how long
could you last before your teeth fell out?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you stopped brushing your teeth.
Plaque is a sticky film made up of bacteria,
leftover food particles and saliva.
It helps other types of bacteria adhere to your teeth,
meaning it only helps you most get dirtier and dirtier.
So we know plaque can grow pretty quickly on your teeth in just one day.
But what would happen if you stopped brushing your teeth
for the rest of your life? Before we get to that,
what lives inside your mouth? On an average day,
over 6 million bacteria from 700 different species
live inside your mouth. Now not all of those are bad for you.
In fact, a lot of them promote good health,
but some bacteria living in your mouth are harmful to you.
That's why you brush your teeth since it helps get rid of that harmful bacteria.
And now you've suddenly decided to stop.
Brushing week has gone by,
and you're starting to notice some serious, bad breath.
People stay a little bit further away from you when you try to talk to them,
but bad breath would be the last thing on your mind.
After just a week of not brushing your teeth,
the plaque in your mouth would begin to harden and form tartar.
This is like a really hard plaque that discolors your teeth.
And at this point only a dentist would be able to get rid of it.
And on top of all that your enamel would begin to be damaged as
bacteria continue to multiply in your mouth. Okay?
That's one week of not brushing. Let's fast,
forward to one month in this crazy experiment.
So here's some good news.
If you normally spend an average of four minutes a day,
brushing your teeth at this point, you've saved two hold hours. Hey,
that's enough to watch a movie. And then we have some bad news,
which is everything.
After not brushing your teeth for a month.
You'd start to get cavities.
These holes in your teeth would continue to get deeper and deeper.
And they eventually fill with pus.
As time goes by the cavities in your teeth would get worse and worse.
You'd also start to develop Gingervitis,
which would inflame the gums around your teeth. Now,
good luck trying to eat anything, because at this point,
your gums would be incredibly sensitive.
This would continue for about a year. And after that,
you not brushing your teeth would lead to periodontitis.
This is when the inner layer of your gums starts to pull away from your teeth
and form pockets, which would collect food and bacteria.
Now, with all this extra bacteria in your mouth,
your immune system would start to destroy your gums.
And after your gums start to go away,
you lose your teeth as they decade and fell out of your mouth.
And now that you don't have any teeth,
you could start to have health issues outside your mouth.
A study in California found that people who didn't brush their teeth daily had a
20 to 65% greater chance of getting dementia
than those who brushed multiple times a day.
And for all the guys out there who decided to stop brushing their teeth
well, that could lead to erectile dysfunction.
In a 2012 study,
it was found that 53% of the patients with erectile dysfunction
also had severe periodontitis.
So not brushing your teeth forever would not only affect your mouth,
but other parts of your body as well.
My advice just push your teeth.
It only takes a couple of minutes a day and you'll be a healthier person for it.
Okay. So it's obvious that not brushing your teeth would be pretty awful.
Another thing that would be terrible for you only drinking Coca-Cola,
but we'll leave that story for another, what else.